welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and even when we were
told to get over it
probably by steve trevor still us fans
persisted
and demanded that the snyder cup be
released
i still can't believe that it's actually
happening and we have a whole host of
new updates to talk about
including the announcement of a new
trailer changes to the ending
army of the dead easter eggs a possible
blu-ray release date
and confirmation that harry lennox will
indeed be martian manhunter in the movie
we're gonna be breaking it all down but
if you like the video or
if you don't not like the video then
please drop a thumbs up or down and make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns like this each and every day
we're giving away three copies of both
the hobbit and lord of the rings on 4k
but i'll talk about that more towards
the end of the video anyway
zack snyder's justice league is due to
release a march this year
and according to digital bits the
blu-ray dvd
and ultra hd discs will actually be
releasing the same month
a lot of people have been crying out for
physical copies of the film to be
released
and i'm a huge 4k collector so seeing
that it's getting distributed
through traditional means it indeed
warms my heart
now the update which was posted on the
digital bits basically outlines all the
upcoming 4k
and blu-ray titles that are releasing
over the next couple of months
and it contains a huge list of films and
their release times
amongst these is clearly listed zack
snyder's justice league
as releasing in march along with wonder
woman 1984 which will be coming out the
following month
now whilst this is unconfirmed at the
moment the digital bits
aren't really a site that make things up
for clicks i'm looking at you youtube
and therefore it doesn't seem like they
would post this unless they had at least
some reason to
a lot of people in the uk where hbo max
isn't available
were very worried that they wouldn't be
able to see the series
and that they'd have to wait until it
was released digitally this happened in
the case of wonder woman 1984
and though this was dropped in cinemas
i'm still not even sure if it's so on
vod
however with the project being released
in march and the blu-ray reportedly
coming then too
it does kind of give us an idea of how
things are gonna line up
now though we don't have a specific
release date for it we do know that it's
gonna be split up into four chapters
and therefore it's gonna probably carry
across over four weeks the blu-ray can
likely only be released once those four
episodes have been shown on hbo max
so it does seem likely that the first
week of march might actually be the time
that we get the first episode
that's just me hoping and praying but
you know that makes it makes a lot of
sense to me
i'm actually very curious to see how
they're gonna handle the physical
release
and whether it'll be put out in episodic
format or if it'll be one continuous
film
now i'm no disk space aficionado but
from personal experience
when films are over three hours in the
4k format they tend to take up quite a
lot of space
even with a 2kdi avengers endgame had to
be massively compressed to fit on one
disc
and in the case of lord of the rings
they actually had to split the film
across
multiple entries in order to get the
extended versions out there
so i can see it being split up as an
episodic release
probably across two discs this would
mean that there's not really any
compromise on image quality
and we can get the full imax level
pictures displayed on our screens
i didn't buy no two grand oled in a 4k
blu-ray player to watch 2kd i made or
you're mad mate
sorry that's my inner jody coming out
now as for the trailer
there is rumored to be one coming out at
the end of january
start of feb when asked about it snyder
posted on vero that he was working on it
so it does seem like it won't be too
long before we get some new footage
although the jan feb stuff could be true
i kind of feel like it might be released
more towards march
as that's closer to the release date and
it will mean that we aren't waiting a
number of weeks before it's out
it makes sense for them to hold off on
stuff just to keep the hype there
and as this is going to be the final
trailer it's probably best to drop it
just before the release date
now as for the movie itself we have some
new updates on the ending
and in an exclusive exclusive exclusive
report from collider
that harry lennox will be playing
martian manhunter in the film
mega exclusive this which had known this
two years ago when i was making videos
about how he was playing marshy
manhunter in the movie whilst collider
were putting out articles saying that it
didn't exist
but we'll not go into that we'll not go
into that one
not get into how you lied and ruined my
entire life
anyway here's the clip in which lennox
confirms that he will indeed be playing
martian manhunter in the movie
i think you know we could put the rumor
to bed yes
i am the martian manhunter
yeah so i am eternally grateful to zach
uh for seeing it through you know it
came about in a very circuitous
way right you know the fans demanded uh
that his vision
be given a a fair hearing
fair viewing if you will and so uh he
actually
tagged me on a on a post it was an
instagram post where he showed
the canisters of the of the cut
of night or cut and uh and so it's
complete
when exactly it comes out i don't know
i've i've heard march
uh i don't know when in march uh or even
if it will be in march but that said
you know i'm over the moon about it and
to be in all honesty
uh i had never heard of martian
manhunter
until until these uh until zach
you know brought him to light and of
course a lot of fans
did know about martian manhunter but i
tell you it's uh
he's a founder of the justice league a
co-founder
um a very powerful uh figure
and it's it's going to be great to be up
there with batman and superman and my my
pals
so yeah i'm uh once again like a kid at
a candy store
he's what he said he never heard of
martian manhunter
get him ah now obviously the guy's over
the mood about this
and there was a lot of worry over
whether zach would actually be able to
film the scenes with harry
because they didn't have the time to get
them before he exited the original
theatrical release
when the additional footage was being
filmed it was of course happening during
the pandemic
so there was a lot of worry over whether
martian manhunter would actually be
included in the release
so it looks like things are all coming
together for it and some of the things
that he says
makes me think that we have some clues
about where and when he could appear in
the movie
now originally in the script martian
manhunter was supposed to show up at the
end
after it was revealed that he and
general swanwick were one in the same
he was reportedly going to be
accompanied by green lantern not long
after this
but things are still up in the air over
whether he will be appearing in the cut
or not
manhunter was meant to show up as bruce
was starting to uncover the truth about
darkseid
and this would kind of tease that bigger
threats were coming down the line
however the way that harry talks about
being up there with superman and batman
makes me think that he might even appear
in the climactic battle
at the end against steppenwolf perhaps
he could show up at the last second to
help everyone to get out
and maybe he will even appear alongside
them as they stand together for the team
shot
that is of course speculation at the
moment but there is another possible
position he could play which we'll talk
about in just a bit
now because we're going into the ending
the next part of the video will contain
spoilers for it and it's cliffhanger so
if you don't want anything ruined then i
recommend that you turn off now
anyway if you're still here thanks for
sticking around and the film is
apparently going to close out with a
flash forward of five years
in which we'll see the nightmare
sequence play out in full effect
the world has been completely decimated
and according to reports we'll see a
road weary batman
joker mira played by amber turd flash
and deathstroke
now according to the original
storyboards that were mapped out by jim
lee
the characters would be seen dragging a
badly damaged cyborg into batman's base
which is what the bat cave had been
transformed into however i have heard
that things go beyond this
and that we actually see them going into
it which is where we discover that
they've been mapping out the cosmic
treadmill
we know that cyborg has hologram
technology so it is possible that he
could even show them a diagram of this
before we cut to black flash of course
used that item to travel back in batman
v superman
and therefore setting it up here means
that if they want to leave things in a
cul-de-sac
we at least have some closing of the
chapter however no one wants that yeah
get to it tomorrow we want more snyder
stuff
that little side little side theory here
but but i actually think that walter
hamada may have even said the cul-de-sac
comment
in order to get hashtag restore the side
of his trending
but yeah mike might be giving him a bit
too much credit there but i can't think
of any other reason why he'd take a poop
on the project like that
anyway zach is of course busy with other
stuff
namely his netflix movie which we know
is called army of the dead
however that didn't stop the director
dropping a little tribute to the
mythical snyder cut
in his brand new post-apocalyptic world
snyder
recently released a still from the
upcoming film that showed the cast of
characters
entering a bank vault filled with cash
however the people with superman's
vision amongst you
may have noticed that in the top left
corner there appears to be some
canisters
that look very similar to the snyder cut
ones that were used to house the film
these were posted on zak's vero just
when the movement was starting to pick
up
and they were used as a way to shut
people up who were denying that the cut
even existed
we won't forget never forget and never
forgive
anyway it's a cool little easter egg and
i don't hate you collider
you're special i love you and i'm glad
that we can experience this scyther cut
in march
that's every update that we have so far
this week and obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on them
now as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
draw where we're giving away three
copies of the hobbit and lord of the
rings 4k box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the updates
the winners are going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of january so best of
luck to everyone who takes part
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the spider-man 3 updates which will be
linked on screen right now
we talk about trailer stuff what's going
to be in the film
and a lot more so it's definitely worth
watching if you
if you're bored right now let's be
honest now without the way
if not and you've got a fun for life
well thanks for sitting through the
video
as always i've been paul you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace